what's going on since Greg Alba here I
shot my episode 1 in to review of the
defenders and there were some points in
there that I was making about how I felt
like the first two episodes would feel
more rewarding after you know some later
episodes when the team starts coming
together and I'm ready feeling that
episode 3 a lot of people have asked me
to do a reaction to the last 10 minutes
of this episode based off of the hallway
I'm assuming we're gonna see that
hallway fight I'm pretty excited for it
because the sentences are pretty damn
good actually let's get this show on the
road
any rain has just met Alexander
[Music]
there's no
you can't hide anymore just look like
financial yes it's what you do
thank you those bad speech bin Jones
[Music]
you have it most everything yes
oh my nipples are so hard
yeah
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
seems to be moving a little better
I am Ben Jones you got better man you
got a lot better
I was set
[ __ ] yeah
nice sweet I love that one
it was the best it was pretty good oh
you talk about confrontation
oh we can't you can't see nice
[Music]
whoa
I was
[Music]
yeah I was like a necessary backflip I
like that
[Music]
[Music]
these flips actually certify flips
invites useless oh the double sword
damn strengthen those it's you like
superhuman
Oh
Oh trailer moment oh it's so cool seeing
them all together Hey yes
[Music]
yeah baby
[Music]
dude yes that was so cool man I really
like the entire episode actually I found
a very need to be seeing a lectures
whole backstory I found it very
interesting to see a lecturer being
resurrected is the black sky and then
we're learning more about Alexandra
she's obviously one of the main people
at the hand she's been resurrected she's
been around for lifetimes and seeing how
she's become like this mother figure for
the new Electra is very fascinating to
me you know I have the first two
episodes I found kind of dull and a
little stretched out but after watching
this third episode I'm like I know it
was all necessary in the first two
episodes they knew what they were doing
all these writers knew what they were
doing the scene when matt murdock and
jessica jones are in the interrogation
room i love that a cat-and-mouse type of
banter the chemistry between Luke Cage
and iron fist I find it be quite on par
I'm not a big fan of Finn Jones and but
in this episode I thought I did a pretty
good job and I think his chemistry with
Mike Colter makes his performance even
better actually starting to get hints at
Luke Cage being sort of like a mentor to
Danny ran in certain life areas and one
of my complaints about the last couple
episodes was it felt like the main plot
wasn't feeling all too personal to me
after watching this episode I'm really
starting to feel that the main plot
outside of their own personal life
dramas the main plot you know with Danny
rands personal vendetta against the hand
the transition started to feel more
natural to me here when they were
cutting around to the different
characters and that moment when he meets
the kids mother gives her the lotto
tickets and she starts to cry when she
finds out her son died I started tearing
up a little bit actually that was that
was really well I don't know who that
actress is but I really got me emotional
he'd made the plot for Luke Cage feel
more personalized going on this mission
and then with Matt Murdock finding out
that's a lecture a holy [ __ ] dude I
really thought this episode was great
I'm not gonna assume that's like the
best fight sequence of the entire season
I'm sure later episodes would probably
have better fights but the fight was
really cool watching the four of them
coming together see them all on screen
on that
L
it's a really cool shot man I'm pretty
excited for this you know it really did
actually make the four already like I
thought like me I have so five or six
will make the first two episodes better
how do you think the first two episodes
got a lot better because of this one
episode right now it's really starting
to pick up steam I'm really oh yeah this
is the [ __ ] alright guys well yeah
comments are temporarily disabled until
I'm done with the defenders and caught
up on Game of Thrones too if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell you can follow me at the Greg alb
on Instagram and Twitter they have a
patreon go check that shiznit out it's
awesome I put out a tweet recently
asking people what episodes of the
defenders have moments in them that are
probably worth doing reactions to if
they said three five six and eight I
believe are the main ones I have them
written down the the ones that were most
recommended love you guys take care